so at fifth grade so you're probably I
guess that's about 11 years old or so
was that sort of where your secular
awakening was was happening is that the
time of that or how religious actually
was was your family where you were you
guys away from it already or break that
down for me well my family was my family
was sort of liberal religious on me
there were Muslim they were believing
Muslims we used to go through the you
know we did the Ramadan thing we stood
where she s we to do the Muharram
morning my parents used to pray you know
on and off but usually they made it to
like two or three times a day you know
on average so you know they were there
must be an interesting diagram of people
praying and then the sort of drop off as
it gets later in the day right I I don't
know a lot of Muslims who actually
believe pray five times a day every time
I watch TV and it's you know this is a
slight tangent but every time you know
you google North American Muslim or
American Muslim you'll get a whole
pictures of people with head scarves and
you know people in mosques and so on but
they're just as much representative of
us Muslims as as you know any militant
group right Brett's not what care and
it's none or not which is exactly why we
should all be talking to people like you
more because I have no faith that the
media is giving us examples of any
forget religion ethnicity whatever it is
the media gives us such bad examples of
everybody that that's why we have to
talk to the outliers write me a you
understand it in a way and I'm sorry
we're going away from your original
questions that's fine that's fine I'm
yet I understand it in a way because you
know for instance if there's something
some story relating to Christianity
you're not exactly usually gonna call in
a pastor or you know somebody who's was
a priest or something like that as an
expert with G and E but um the thing
with Muslims it's different when you
think Jerry Seinfeld with david
letterman you don't think jus right but
with right well I don't think
Letterman's Jewish but either way I
thought he was comedian so it's it's
close enough comedian is a whole
different answer separate I think right
that's that's another thing right but um
you know when you win win a cup
Muslims I mean Dave Chappelle dr. oz
Shaq O'Neal like all of these guys I
mean these are people who are Muslims
but that's not who you sit that that's
not the representation even though
they're right here in front of our faces
so when you see it on TV it's always the
one with the headscarf and almost every
non wasn't my no work so the Muslim of
work has gone for beer with him
afterwards you know a lot of people have
dated by some girls and they very few of
them actually wear the headscarf but i'm
pretty sure if Shaq was the main
representative for a Muslim things would
be extremely different right now yep
wouldn't they yeah probably probably for
the better um so wait so tell me a
little more so your family so you guys
were sort of religious but not that
religious you were getting some of this
at the school but that was obviously
Americanized right keep going so I mean
my my main the first time I was truly
skeptical of that religion and God was
when I was five years old and I actually
had a cousin and she was three and this
is said that she'd lived in London and
she had childhood leukemia so you know
she was close to my age I was five she
was three you know we playmates and when
she was dying everybody who came into
the room so this is like an hour in the
culture you know last moments everyone
walks and those some kids were there he
was there and it's a few know what a
child's death is specially from cancer
it's absolutely horrific you know so
cancer doesn't discriminate same amount
of pain and adult feels is what a
three-year-old child would cool so and
at that time there wasn't really any
good cure for childhood acute
lymphoblastic leukemia either so at that
point my mother and my aunt were praying
and crying and I was standing there with
my father and asked my father I'm like
you know what's going on I was watching
her in pain and he said that God's
taking her back God's taking her to a
better place and keeping girl with him
so I'm thinking okay that's that's not
such a bad thing so why are they crying
and why they praying so hard and they're
like they're they're begging God not to
take her away they want him to you know
like stop the pain or not take away and
to me that can my mind used to play
tug-of-war at school so I was thinking
of the
a war game where there's this God is
all-powerful apparently and we're on the
other end we're playing and it just
seemed like a very sadistic thing to do
yeah it also it also sounds like such a
losing proposition if you're the
believer so if in this case you're your
father assuming he was a believer or
that maybe he was just playing the role
as a father but it's a losing
proposition if you pretty much know
medically that the child is not going to
make it and yet you have these people
praying and you know the outcome is
pretty much in front what are you
actually saying about prayer is also an
interesting angle I mean that's the
other thing and I think if God is like
all-powerful there's a three year old
kid in pain you don't and find I
understand you know you have to take the
kid back that don't like don't draw it
out don't draw out the agony because
cancer that's a terrible so we you know
at that point the clarity of fibril of
mine I obviously that I remember this
very clearly it's one of my earliest
strongest memories just because the
intensity of it and after that I thought
I was like okay nobody's really gonna be
happy with this God character anymore
but the next week every ritual
everything God he was a hero you know
everyone who's continued pranked him so
it didn't make a lot of sense to me and
then after that I thought I was like
maybe well all these guys and all the
adults grown ups think it makes sense so
maybe I'm the one who's crazy but then
I'd see i'd watch TV and there'd be a
disaster natural disaster tornado or a
flood or something and the lone survivor
or two would say you know I'm god bless
you know God saved me I'm so thankful to
God knows I'd always think you know what
did the other people do so as a kid it
was always there and then I dialed in
and out of being religious to some
extent like whenever had exams finals
that well that's where the prayer would
kick in yeah so it was like my cousin
used to call the bribing God like
reviving God he was a very religious guy
yeah the bad god probably took your
bribes I'm guessing you were pretty good
student hey the end it turned out that I
was fairly yeah I did well in school I I
did turned out whether I prayed or not
God somehow was ok with me but all those
kids with HIV in Africa
how yeah just somehow my grades were ok
but the HIV for the kids in Africa not
so much yeah all right so you you have
this awakening and it's happening where
where was the full sort of more adult
version of your awakening were you still
in Saudi Arabia or was that when you had
left already I had I'd left I'd gone
I've gone to medical school at that
point in Pakistan i finish i completed
it and towards the end of it i had
actually really started reading the well
i'd started reading the scripture and
everything the Quran when I was much
younger I think when the internet came
around and I wanted to do more research
I was able to find more things so if
this was around 99er so that was already
in my 20s I'm a little up there and so
so I started you know when I actually
started reading it then and when people
got more and more defensive about it the
more I talked especially in Pakistan
when you talk to people they give you
all of these responses like you know
those aren't true Muslims or you know
this is it's a bit of peace or you know
that thing that you're recording from
the Quran that's just mistranslated or
misinterpreted or it's a metaphor you
know that whatever the excuse was
eventually I started seeing through it
and then I i think it was actually one
day when it hit me like this I shouldn't
even be considering this and this is a
guy lived inside a fish you know there's
yeah it says it says in it I hear that
you know the in the Quran for me was a
Quran for a lot of people survival and
everything but by the way we should note
that they're all equally crazy there's
plenty of evil stuff in all of them we
want you know we want to be good
liberals here so let's not pile on one
right there is plenty of awful stuff in
the Old Testament well let me sure they
always say that if Moses hadn't
hallucinate adapt the Old Testament and
you know Muhammad could have plagiarized
it this it is and there's a lot of
similarities in has no pork there's no
foreskin for miles there's Shalom and
Salam and then both of their nicknames
or bow it's in a way there's a you know
there are a lot
similarities between especially between
Judaism and Islam and and the violence
in the books is absolutely and that's
that's an obvious thing but I used to
think I'm like what are you doing when
people would quote verse 4 34 which says
that you can beat your wife if you fear
disobedience as a last resort and they
justify it now like well no it actually
means this or it's only as a last resort
nice to think I'm like if I had written
this in my book and the book came out
last week you guys would be killing me
for this i mean there's the word you
wouldn't be looking for contacts you can
be looking at alternative
interpretations that's a luxury that we
only afford to holy books i mean we
don't read Alice in Wonderland that way
resurrected you know the and did you
know people like for example Reza Hassan
so on be like that is it this is we
should not read this literally like in
the worst thing is the people who read
it literally I was actually on a show I
was on the agenda with steve paikin here
in Toronto and I was sitting next to
Shabbir Ali who's a an Islamic scholar
and at one point he actually said he's
like look people miss quote the Quran by
quoting it literally and I was just
thinking that's the there was one of
most amazing sentences that's a great
quote right there yeah he's a great guy
but he said and I used to think I'm like
I understand why they're so terrified of
people quoting it literally any script
had liver because it's terrifying if you
quote if you quote those words exactly
the way that they're written or exactly
the way they were said by God apparently
then it's a terrifying thing you know so
they say well you have to look at the
interpreters and the scholars and then
you listen the scholars and they're
saying these human beings there are
explanations of what's God what God's
Word is actually means more than what
God's Word is itself which again doesn't
make any sense and Isis and al-qaeda and
the Taliban these are these people
they're not quoting scholars I mean the
third they're quoting scripture
recording the deep yeah you know after
the Paris attacks I i got into it on
twitter with one of my one of my friends
on the Left who were immediately was you
know within while the thing I think
while the event was still happening so
literally they hadn't caught anybody yet
I mean
there were bodies still on the floor at
the theater he immediately went to the
American foreign policy stuff and then a
few minutes after that they released the
guys who did it Isis actually released
the statement and there was a ton of
scripture in there and I said well what
do you think about this and then the
conversation sort of dwindled off into
nothing and I and I think that's part of
what this whole schism here on the left
that we've been talking so much about is
related to you know like it's scripture
it's written word that somebody is
believing and taking into action and
then also there's a lot of messed up
foreign policy stuff by every country in
the world yeah I I always find it i find
it interesting that whenever i'm
debating or i'm having a discussion that
anybody usually if it's someone who's
moderate or someone or an academic or
someone else in islamic studies for
instance um they don't want to talk
about the scripture like well come on
let's not talk about the scripture as if
it's sort of beneath them so you know
we're gonna talk about the social
logical implications with this you know
how does religion work out as I did
identity formation and all of these
other things economics and so on but
whenever I talk to a guy with a beard
you know someone who's more
fundamentalist and I like at times else
and I said this on the show too Shabbir
Ali to I was like oh let's not get into
the whole Scripture thing but they
almost always turn out say no that's
what's important that's what the
religion is so the people who are
actually believing it and going along
with the tenants of it and actually
following the example of the prophet and
so on these are people who actually take
scripture very very seriously the rest
of people don't and I think it's because
there is an element of rationality and
then they just can't believe they're
like okay this is a book but nobody
really believes is yeah so last week my
guess was Peter bogosian who you're
probably familiar with and he wrote a
book called a manual for creating
atheists and one of the things that I
thought was most interesting about it
was that he basically said you know
because these beliefs are not based in
critical thinking or rationality and
that people have to take this leap of
faith that actually if you can really
sit someone down and you do it sort of
with the right intent and and a clear
mind you can start pulling the the
underpinnings away
in an effective way and you can actually
convert people in into free thinkers I'm
gonna guess that you've done quite a bit
about yourself I did the only reason I
do what I do dave is uh because of that
anytime somebody tells me it's like
another way that you talk to people it's
not gonna work people aren't gonna
change their mind um that is absolutely
not true and I've got um you know if you
look at my inbox like my email inbox I
almost on a daily basis you know I get
messages I mean the most recent one was
not if you read that post at one fire
hose by friend of mine see me Ramon she
wrote about the dead telling difference
between a moderate and radical she lives
in California she's a pediatrician I'll
send it to you yeah please do it yeah
and she um so it went viral got
thousands and thousands of shares and so
on and she got a message just a few days
ago and there was this woman who I she
wore than the cob he's very conservative
family and she'd read it and um she has
now she's seriously thinking about
taking it off like oh it's completely
shaken the way that she's think about
things the way that she grew up and
these are stories that I hear every day
and I hear them more than ever in
muslim-majority countries and and this
is what's so interesting is that in
North America are generally but the
Muslims because they're they're used to
the free speech and the open discourse
and everything they are they like to
have a respectful approach so like okay
criticize religion please be respectful
of us they don't like the tone that
somebody like for example like Richard
Dawkins or Bill Maher takes right
however in the Muslim in these Muslim
majority countries whether living under
these sort of theocratic dictatorship so
even though they're not officially
theocratic dictatorship Saul most all of
them are um for them they that really
resonates for them with them the more
aggressive tone because they're a press
why they can't speak so they're angry
they're frustrated the last person that
they heard who spoke went out he got
hacked to death and in Dhaka and yeah up
so you know they they are they're angry
and they're frustrated and they they
want that kind of
they feel like the respectful discourse
is the luxury of the privileged people
who are able to values like freedom of
speech and then you can take that who
take that for granted that that I mean
that's really fascinating because you
know I've talked a lot about how people
you know especially its Dawkins in Mar
are the two that have sort of become you
know the most outspoken on atheism
really and talking about the doctrine of
Islam I think they're pretty boi pretty
clear it's out there in the
muslim-majority country so yeah but I
what I think what I think is interesting
here is that I hear from atheists will
say well talkin zamar they're there to
fence you know it's too offensive
there'd be you know they're putting out
too much and they're not speaking in a
you know a friendly way so atheists are
angry at them for being atheists but
interestingly you're saying that in
foreign places in foreign countries they
need to hear it in that light and that's
incredible because they actually want to
say it that way I mean if you the most
sort of aggressive sounding atheists
that you'll meet from the Muslim world
are the ones who actually grew up there
yeah the ones with the accents are the
ones who made it here after living there
who think that all you know Americans
kind of take freedom of speech and
polite discourse and so on for granted
so they are angry they want a more angry
sort of expression of it but there I
mean there is a point i do understand
why people different things work on
different people i was give the example
of the civil rights movement how you
know Rosa Parks acted in silence you
know she was sitting on the bus and she
said I'm not gonna move back on the
other hand Martin Luther King was the
diplomat you know so he was he was sort
of more political he was conciliatory
used to try to make reasoned arguments
and talk to the other side on the other
hand he had Malcolm X who was more
militant and all of those approaches had
had a role that are very cute Roland and
they work on different people um my
approach is probably more sort of the I
tried to be reasonable I have reasonable
arguments I try to do that at least but
I do appreciate people who do the kind
of thing to belmar and Richard
consumed because I know that it
resonates I know that it's a um it's
very satisfying to a lot of people
growing up there and I remember when I
was growing up there whenever I would
hear people say things like that was
George Carlin at the time but you know I
remember you know seeing little things
that George Carlin that had done and the
way that he talked about religion it was
just so in your face and so like naked
Lee open some of it that it was
extremely satisfying to watch but that's
something that you could not see and
you'd show it to your friends was on a
VHS tape and show to your friends in the
clip where you said it and yeah you can
see the shock on their faces and it was
this is something really satisfying
about yeah well I I tell my friend Kelly
Carlin who's been on the show who's
George's daughter I tell Kelly literally
once a week I'll call her or text her
and say God God ironically I'll say gosh
you know I really wish that your dad was
around now because we're so trapped and
I think this will get us to the next
portion of this conversation but we're
so trapped in this pc world right now
and we're so afraid of language and
we're so afraid of offending everybody
and already as you've said sometimes you
have to offend people to actually break
through it's not your style clearly
right like you're not looking trim and
everybody but I end up doing it anyway I
think that the needs of the price but
you know that the thing is like I hear
this a lot i hear a lot of people say
this especially a lot of my Muslim
friends in here living in the US and in
Canada is that um the free freedom of
speech does not mean the freedom of to
offend and I would say to them I'm like
there's no such thing as freedom of
speech without freedom defense yeah
every that there is absolutely no major
revolutionary change that has ever
happened in history that did not piss
off a lot of people and that includes
Islam I mean there's a reason that
Muhammad was chased out of Mecca you
know when he came back and if you want
to talk about blasphemy you know writing
drawing cartoons is nothing compared to
the way he came to the Kaaba and he
smashed all the idols of the quraish
with his stick yeah she just smashed him
to pieces and yeah these are sacred gods
so you know he himself started Islam
that way and Jesus was crucified for a
reason you know India said these were
the original blasphemer so anytime
someone asks me that talks about being
aggressive and tone and so on I I like
to tell them and I actually believe in
like I'm essentially following the
example of the Prophet Muhammad what
we're supposed to do it's exactly
randoms what you should be doing
you